small one which is a size card of
manuscrip credit card of manuscript
which is Matthew 28 I believe yes but
the full month full New Testament
literally 100 years after Jesus no 100
100 years okay than that more than that
they said so the point here is yes when
the Christian say we have many
manuscript doesn't mean you have the
full manuscript okay that's why when
when B you know B by the way yeah B is a
he was is a school like
Christianity in North Carolina
University he was himself Christian then
he start doubting Christianity and he
wrote a book called The in Jesus then he
wrote a book loss of scriptures then he
wrote a book loss of Christianity okay
he had a debate with a Christian expert
of Manus called William wace if I
remember exactly hold this let me get
you the the day correctly you can watch
it by yourself the Christian School has
said clearly we we we cannot be so sure
what really Jesus
said
here you mix
it for the debate then iwitness account
for example I'm witnessing I'm observing
something here so I'm doing I'm writing
it down okay then what happened five
1,000 1,000 years later you have my
testimony but it's not my own writing
you have a copy of a copy of a copy of a
copy of a copy of my
book so when you say we have a a account
of eyewitnesses that's what you think
but when we go back to the new to the to
the manuscript the earliest one we have
is 400 years
later just have to
disagree
okay I'm every Friday but can you tell
me what is the manuscript
and what is it that's not full it yeah
that's small
one yeah that's what what 875 yeah 175
no 075 yeah AB so 75
years within lifetime which
one so within the lifetime of when when
people no no no that's not true that's
not true yeah uh sorry that's uh
let me just get you debate for you to
know I think someone told you that's not
William debate of
I
want second course get the second's
[Music]
day yes Wallace so here can we reach the
Bible so uh what his name Daniel Wallace
sorry Daniel Wallis Daniel Wallace okay
and this it was like over 2 hours I
watched all of it okay and you the
earliest manuscript here I'll show you
the ear
[Music]
manuscript
of you
the first complete copy of a single New
Testament books around 200 and the
earliest complete copy of the New
Testament Kodak stic date the 4th
Century that saying the whole yeah the
whole manuscript the whole together as
for the the earliest what they call it
English uh um no pches is it P
parchments parchment parchments how is
spell
itz ar is not it's
Matthew it's not coming out but it was
to use our
ear part let me see if
yeah check it
because like I was saying Islam what
what makes it fragment fragments that's
it p52 that's it the earliest manuscript
of the New Testament text is a business
card size fragment from the Gospel of
John yeah not not Corin that's it Corin
the whole the whole book
of no no no no I don't think my friend
we'll anyway on Friday here
cuz I can get you like from your own
Christian Scholars speak about issue
your name my name Shi sh what's your
name H H okay my name nice to meet you
man so do you believe in Jesus to be God
yes fully God fly man yes for real time
you have to go all yeah no problem no
problem all right have a nice weekend
nice thank you very much take care